Hello everyone.
Thank you so much for coming today guys.
How is everybody?
I'm so excited.
Our first group collab.
Oh my gosh.
So exciting.
Oh no worries.
No worries.
Thanks for hosting us.
No, no.
Everyone doesn't know actually what we're doing yet.
We're definitely gonna play games like after the stream,
right?
We're gonna play all the cabinets.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I was like, we're gonna open up and like look for plates
and just gonna steal my stuff.
Like, oh, hey, Vicky.
Oh, don't mind us.
We're just gonna take some of these snacks.
I'm rummaging through your kitchen.
Now, guys, talking of stream, we have got things to do
today, haven't we, everyone?
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
Yeah.
I'd like to move over to the board game.
table in the arcade.
Should we go have a look?
Let's play some board games.
This amazing board was put together by Mint Phantom Games.
Would you like to explain the board mint?
Oh yes indeed.
So we have this wonderful board set in our lovely virtual
Akihabara.
And so...
What did I make the colors?
I couldn't remember even.
Oh wait, we have it.
Hold on.
Yeah, we're just, we're good to get to know us a little bit
more through all these questions and whoever finishes first.
No, I don't think we came up with something.
Whoever finishes first could make like a batzu for the other
two people.
Yeah, oh yeah.
Batzu?
Really?
I don't want to leave batzu up to chat.
I don't know what they're going to say.
All right.
I'm going to roll guys.
I'ma roll.
Are you ready?
Haki-daki.
Oh, I got a one, guys, so...
A one.
Cool.
That's great.
That's really great.
Question from the members.
Okay.
What's your question, guys?
Victoria Roman.
Yes.
Do you remove your socks with your toes or with your hands?
Who removes it with their toes?
Is this a thing?
Wait, you don't remove it with your toes?
No?
I like, I step on the other sock and then I pull my foot
out.
Oh, yeah, that would do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's another one too.
I will admit, I think one time where I, for some reason I
was like, I don't know, I was like type and sewing.
I think I did remove one with my mouth once.
One time!
You're judging for toes?
You removed it with your mouth?
It was one time!
Let's do a group one so we can all answer something.
What are your favorite ice cream flavors?
Shall we do it in the tune of the song?
I'm gonna say yeah.
Min-chan!
Hi!
Nani-Nani-kaki!
Cookies and cream!
Yori-m-a-nata!
Libby-chan!
Hi!
Nani-kaki-kaki!
Vanilla with rainbow sprinkles Yorimo anata Well actually if
they have honey But not very many places have honey So
Hachimitsu Yorimo anata Oh Puki What do you What do you
Rosemary ripple Yorimo anata You guys have Rosemary ripple?
I don't know what that is Oh okay thing i don't know like
it's just it's just nice it's very sweet here we go five
five no one two three four uh i think that says back back to
the star back to star i'm about to do the best roll ever
just you wait and see oh oh i'm ready oh okay i also have a
question No.
How do you like your steak?
Oh!
How well done do you have your steak?
Actually, is it okay if I ask both of you guys this?
Because I need to know.
It just says one about a person.
I like medium rare.
Medium rare?
What about you, Vicky?
I also like medium rare.
Oh, we're so, we're so back.
This is...
This is why I love you guys.
This is why I love you.
Okay.
Me too!
Whoa!
Six.
Damn!
Minto?
Yes.
That's my name.
Don't wear it out.
Okay.
Here we go.
Minto!
It's been over a month since your last book recommendation.
Book with strange quotes.
Oh, I love books.
What does this mean?
Could we get a new one?
I don't even...
I think I've...
I feel so empowered on my...
own stream to say these things but then when i am when i am
faced with my own with my own actions i get so embarrassed
like all of the all of the staff are listening meant they're
all look look any literature is literature anyone we will
not judge you for what literature you consume because at
least you read what are your favorite and least favorite
japanese snacks
Seaweed flavored crisps That nori shio Oh yeah Love a bit of
that Those sour umeboshi candies That you can get Literally
the worst thing in the world Why do they sell them?
Get that away from my face I'm glad you also don't like
umeboshi I don't like it either It's okay I also don't like
umeboshi Yeah With that medium rare steak And no umeboshi
Yeah, wow.
We're sounding so American.
That's how I don't want them Japanese umeboshi and I want my
steak medium rare.
My steak medium rare.
I want my sweet tea, my medium rare steak and I don't want
none of that umeboshi.
Howdy.
Will you do a podcast like thing?
It doesn't have to be a regular or have a five star runtime.
But three good girls.
What does that mean?
being goofy about stuff is my favorite kind of iashike thank
you that's also very my one of my favorite kinds of iashike
i had an idea right i had that uh that uh that radio show
idea yeah yeah yeah yeah so actually what i want to do is i
want to put together a monthly radio show for us when
possible and it's gonna have different corners so like a
let's look at people's fan art corner or like a Batsu game
corner or in an announcement corner and just different kinds
of like silly and serious corners and stuff.
That'd be so awesome.
Maybe we can like introduce like music on there as well.
We could be like a radio.
Oh yeah.
That'd be so nice.
Highlight some of our new favorites or maybe like talented
people in the community.
Yay.
That sounds like so much fun.
But I'd love to do that with you.
guys yeah all right miss phoebe as a bee do you carry pollen
or dust um i'm first of all i'm not a bee i'm a fairy and so
i got fairy dust but i but maybe my fairy dust is comprised
of something similar to pollen because i'm a flower fairy
does it pollinate does it pollinate do i have pollinate me
if i oh okay i i what Wait.
Wait.
What?
Me too.
I...
Okay.
Can I shake you?
Will pollen come out?
Um...
Do not shake Phoebe.
Do you think Phoebe and Vicky amplify your freakiness?
Or do you try to keep it low key around them?
Well...
I did talk about my books earlier, but I was embarrassed
about my books.
No!
No, don't be embarrassed about the things you love.
I don't love them.
Well, it's like a love game.
Huh?
What?
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
I don't know.
I think, you know, eventually we'll all just be super freaks
altogether.
Anyways.
Oh gosh.
What could it be?
Phoebe!
Two.
Two for Phoebe.
Okay, it's something.
It's something.
What do you like more?
A manicure or a pedicure?
Oh.
Three, two, one.
Pedicure!
Manicure!
Uncertain.
Oh.
Why, why, why manicure, Minto?
Um, I, I crave the touch of someone holding my hair.
Aw.
Lude hand holding.
This is so unbranded for you.
And final roll.
Will Phoebe get, like, 25?
25.
Roll all three and then add them together.
Really?
Yeah, but some extra drama.
Okay, here we go.
What?
Done or high?
You guys want the same spot.
Oh, that's so...
I don't feel like crying for real right now.
It was fake.
And with that, we have the winner announcement.
Your Batsu game, guys.
Next time, you were both on holiday in Japan.
I have some very nice omiyage that I bought recently at the
wasabi farm.
It's a wasabi long-dashab biscuits.
I thought, oh, they might be nice.
chocolate combined together they taste like some kind of
funky wait white chocolate they're like no no no no you
don't understand they're like they're really really bad guys
so you're gonna have to eat one of those each